[Music]
hey what's up folks welcome to the Lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every Tuesday
at 2 p.m. Pacific right here on Gamespot
sweet work on the jib Jeremy he's
getting really good unbelievable we got
a bunch of games on today paper bound
Gauntlet for lots of couch Co-op and
couch competitive action but right now
we got to dudes from rising star games
daveid and Sam thank you very much for
coming along to our wonderful little
couch it's a pleasure to be here thank
very much for having us you guys are in
town you've got like a like a whole host
of games that you're showing off to
press uh just down the road from us like
two blocks away even not even we're too
lazy we're like come in here and show us
your games and we cater to you guys yeah
and we want to use your sweet South as
well course exactly and then 25 minutes
when you're sweating balls you can jump
away we've been outside it's quite cool
in here it's pretty hot this is like the
nice part of the year for San Francisco
right hot yeah guess feel nice the
lighting actually makes me look tan
which is crazy oh really yeah cuz I'm
like transparent
exactly I I got you beat maybe he you
got too many games to show so we're
concentrating on two today yeah uh first
one up uh try first one is try yeah try
and play try try tell me about try try
I'm going to succeed in telling you
about try Okay so try is a um it's a 3D
Puzzle platformer it's developed by
German developers Rat King entertainment
great name you know what a rat king is
right you know ring when all those rats
get tied up together and and all of
their tails and they become I'm pretty
sure it was a character in the Ninja
Turtles also really hope yeah yeah it's
all the Fe season yeah works well
okay so TR sets out to create fun in one
of the more unexpected places which is
trigonometry yeah yeah baby did you have
fun with trigonometry at school oh I
hated it I hated math I was not good at
mathematics whatsoever history and
English way well the upside is you don't
have to be good at math to play try
thank God so uh you're in the realm of
the odd gods and one of the Gods has
gone missing and using the power of the
try uh your your mission is to kind of
hunt them
down Triforce right it's not a Triforce
we can't say
Triforce it's called the triy
power all caps and so it's as simple as
uh clicking the three points of the
triangle and you can create a triangle
anywhere you want PR R and then as soon
as you touch it or you can right click
on it as well it becomes physical and
you can walk on it so this is when you
first get the tri power so it's very
simple to begin with it's kind of just
teaching the player how to use it but
you can do a lot more stuff later in the
game so you can um defy gravity with it
so the gravity becomes centered on the
try you can also deflect spirits and
lasers with it so we're keeping it nice
and simple here for the we're keeping it
nice and simple this knock over that
sweet I didn't knock I collected it I
collected it they got sucked up just
stole it sucked up into my stat your so
they're actually they're just bonuses so
for the completest inside of you you can
delete triangles power delete triangles
with right clicking and the destruction
of triangles is just as essential as the
creation the creation of
triangles stuff right there yeah got
some
if you want to try and complete the game
without deleting triangles you're going
to have a hard time for sure so ghost
dude here is basically you yeah so this
is the mon he's kind of our guide he's
telling to do yeah and he also tells us
about the controversial um powers of the
try cuz it does have a tendency to send
people insane okay but there's there's
more about that in the game and that's a
big one you're going to be over
encumbered with like loose on you this
place I have number of slots in the bag
so these red foxes they're the ones that
are kind of the keys to the level so
they're our primary goal and we can kind
of find out where they are by pressing H
and you you get a general kind of guide
but you're not sure how how close or how
far okay you can see yeah just little
beacons pop up on the overlay can you
have as many triangles out as you please
I'm pretty sure you can just go
absolutely nuts yeah excellent but
there's also a uh score Attack Mode like
a challenge mode and it's about how
quick you can do it how many bonus
statues you can get and also in how few
triangles
Tri nice
awesome Chris sakes Jim on Gamespot chat
asks will tribe you m keyboard only I'm
a PC Gamer but a lazy one uh will you
have controller support I am right there
with
him um I'm not entirely sure at the
moment I think controller support we try
to keep controller support in as many
games as possible so hopefully yeah you
know I think it's also a matter of
ideally it will start off with uh you
know default keyboard mouse combo but if
you know if if the support is there from
the community you know if enough people
get behind the game I think that it will
be something that's possible down the
line at what stage is this up because
you guys kind of work with a lot of um
India developers who are some of which
are using Early Access some of which are
kind of have been out on platforms like
Dora in the past uh is this available at
the moment what stage is this at it's
not available right now it's going to be
um launched on the 9th of October oh man
Tik Tok yep it's in the final
stages it's just the build we're playing
is probably about 90% complete yeah and
there a purely single player campaign
kind of at the moment yeah awesome so
there is the challenge mode and that's
fully supported by online leader as well
so putting all your loot in here yeah
well this is the kind of portal out of
here so I just need my final statue
Indiana J desk yeah you just got to
steal a bunch of stuff that was on by
ancient it's just redecorating you're
not taking it with you you're just
moving around inconveniencing them and
relocating the fun of the place okay
this is back to the start right back to
the start but we didn't have the power
of the try so we couldn't reach that one
at first we going to grab
this yeah so this is the third stage I
believe so the first two were kind of
just your tutorial stage of kind of hand
a little bit of hand
holding well which is never a Bad Thing
these days no when I'm pule platforming
it seems to be pretty much a a
requirement get out of here star into
the portal what's sper so you can see
this is kind of a summary of my gameplay
experience and I've got 14 tries created
in my time and I've only had epoxy 2
statues found of the 11 and you did it
faster than that but we were just idling
before the show
started oh was the time really high yeah
it was like 13 minutes oh wow I'm not
that bad bet you can do this one faster
let's go so I'm guessing the layering
mechanics on top of the regular triangle
one do you ever get a circle you ever
get a
circle it would fit in you know the game
well you just spoiled the sequel thanks
oh yeah good point yeah hexagon oh wait
that's already been
the Pentagon it' just be called hex caps
should we give should we give some fresh
hands a go of this game yeah absolutely
you want to give Chris you think you're
up for oh yeah hell yeah see just push
this thing over as much fun as it is
watching somebody who's completed that
level 7 million times in the past uh the
fresh eyes all right where it's all at
pressing H will give you a kind of
see-through guide
of looking for my eyes hurt so bad so
sat okay okay off that fox juice just go
ahead over here and see what see what's
lies all right here we go triangle
time nice not true
boom I told you man they can try and Run
and Jump this
or choice so the initial like I guess
like initially you're trying to that
might be a jump that do I have to
run
it's fine it's cool dude do you parkour
I got this I know you so parkour right
so if that that's red it's no good you
can actually alter them on the fly as
well so you can around you can also
build triangles off of your existing
triangles which can lead to some
interesting Creations like a square am I
right that's forbidding that will get
you a permanent vand
spoilers all right such a good vandal
we stuff goes missing here in the office
all the time I reckon it's Chris so good
at this yeah except I just knock it on
the ground all right we can knock all
these boxes around like that oh yeah you
want to get them all out of your way get
got of my way boxes oh I can grab them
and move them plir in the twitch chat
asks uh how many stages will there be uh
currently 16 levels cool and there's no
ability to like create your own or share
them around uh not currently it's all in
development I mean not that's in
development but with the game in
development haven't had time to think
about what next see H Sia 61's asking do
you guys have a a price yet for this bad
boy um you just say no look let's look
at the pr guy um which right now none of
the PC titles they have lined up are
going to be over $15 right now we're all
trying to shoot at $12.99 and Below um
and it'll be on Steam so looking forward
to future of releases and sales and all
sorts of cool deals excellent and it's
it's rising star games 10th anniversary
this year also so they've been around
for 10 years so they're kind of they're
r up real quick with a lot of cool
titles well it seems like you guys have
got a bunch of stuff working on at the
moment yeah well seems very new to us
we've had Cloud bu and deadly pre
premonition and now we're just kind of
we really like that kind of Indie um
experience where you can support these
guys who are making new and interesting
products worked count it you got it
getting along I'm just going to get one
of the and if you hold up the the H key
I think it's behind
you it should be over there you go you
got a Bonus one there as well you got
two bonus on I he's already going to
beat
me all right Chris steal a couple of
more amazing pieces
of AR and then we're going to swap it
onto a new game be fine just create 50
triangles in there dropping triangles
over no big deal no big deal boom is
that your first one of those my first
big red yeah big red where's where some
more Big Reds love that it's like a
triping balls every
time what there's another one there man
all right I got to get that obviously
so the later levels in the game they
feature a lot more mechanics and puzzles
and stuff and they take a lot longer to
complete I mean these were still kind of
in the tutorial setting up the player at
this stage yeah first quarter of the
game still yeah all right one more one
more Chris I believe in you like uh see
that's it just take your luds and find
out where the next C
is came into here through so I'm not
sure if I should go
back oh no he's going the right way down
the hall yeah I know yeah yeah in a got
Vita baby it's like S hypervision Mode
yeah got to get the there's a switch
there's a switch on the wall uh behind
you way the other way there you go it's
great now we're like now it's like couch
Co-op single player video games haven't
done that in a while the best kind of
what's up G he's the monk he's he's your
guide I'm not sure if he's a fox if he's
a rabbit I see his little ears up at the
top
though Circle stra him real quick
triangle a bunny
I don't know what he is all right where
we go where we go but I do like the
upside down triangle trees one more you
got it go
away I have a feeling this next one's
going to be difficult more hard you can
delete those he'll tell delete triang
triangles that are under that one
triangle on the right so you can't
delete that one first oh cuz it's it's
supporting behind it it's a loadbearing
triangle it is exactly you can't just
bring it all crashing expain that to oh
so this is this is like a good example
of how you can build triangles connected
to other triangles not just connected to
the environmental also showing the
player how they can dismantle
you that was like when you're in school
and you jump up to hit the doorway yeah
yeah high five the
door oh there you go come on F I know
you're around
here foxy
Fox you got it oh you got it nice that
one always makes me sad not it's the
onlyone in the whole game there's a
story behind that a story behind every
object spoil there's a floating thing
all right let's knock it on to the next
game you guys have got a bunch of games
you need to shift on through them keep
on rocking with our sweet little table
it's the best that was pretty neat yeah
nice work so Tri out in the first week
of October is that right oober yeah Co
October 9th now Kaya is that how you
pronounce itay yeah so we're going to
play that in a second but we're you've
got a bunch of other games that you're
not showing here today can you give us
kind a little rundown on some of those
bad boys Tula um toas kind of like a
very inward thought crazy I don't know
you wanted to describe it Sam it's very
it's insane it looks like you're in a
nightmare asy is that the one Jeremy is
that the one you were saying is some
sort of weird thing where you create a
brother version of yourself is a too
like an evil imagin evil imaginary
friend a sid scrolling Jeremy sorry is
our staff Mystic that he knows all for
Mystics it's a sides scrolling puzzle
game but it's very dark mysterious and
very abstract as well so it takes um the
puzzles are very abstract so it's not
you're normally like doing it logical
it's kind of you got to really open your
mind to get through it but it's yeah
very dark very mysterious cool and all
the yeah and all their titles they have
coming up are very all have very unique
art styles like Tri is very um Eastern
like kind of looking and Asian themed
and Caya is very futuristic it's almost
has all pretty vivid though like this
one as well this Kraken Empire y Empire
you guys only partner with India
developers who've got really good names
awesome names yeah it's on top of our
like name Che
Empire they're all names inspired by
chin maville books so Kay's actually
been like available for a while I think
hasn't it right or is it I remember
seeing this on Dora like a year ago or
something is that right is there a
different version of it okay okay I
think they had like an early different
version shut it
down I don't know this menu is uh it's
pretty cool isn't it you read Space Age
I know do you one yeah that one says
options learn it
yeah so um Kraken Empire they're a
Spanish developer and they're big fans
of the Retro 2D s scrolling kind of
schmu thing and uh they wanted to bring
that that craziness into a 3D World um
so they've done a number of things to uh
to bridge that Gap uh firstly we've got
six planes of Freedom so we've got your
left right forward back which then makes
a different is you got your up and down
so you got your vertical and you've also
got your uh spin Spin and your
pitch and what's cool is you can apply
your Boost to any any one of those
vertices six directions we've got a very
basic I don't make everyone really dizzy
it's like the first time I played the
sent or Colony War I hope you're not
watching this on Oculus Rift anyone oh
my could you
imagine okay so this is the orange world
with the orange ship you kind of go
through everyone's respective worlds to
begin with um and then you can start
experimenting with different ships uh
one of the first things that they've
tried to make like a schmap the enemies
are programms come in front of you
there's a there's a number of
interesting AI Dynamics um it's got
Progressive uh kite has Progressive
difficulty also so if you're you know
excelling at the game at a rapid Pace
it'll ramp up the difficulty of the AI
hun you down what if you're just bonking
into a bunch of
stuff probably fail I need to get my
head in the game this is a lot harder
game to demo live yeah I can Buzz around
quite easily but when you get into the
mode into the zone it gets really quick
I need to get my Advanced boost I notic
you like playing sideways with your ship
at like there's no up down left or right
in
space do tail the enem G is down up or
down but it has a lot of Unique
Mechanics that I think a lot of people
um are going to U I just noticed those
gigantic space coffins that you're
flying around that's wild those are
totally big space coffins um but it has
it has a weird feel like it's it's like
part Star Fox part Colony Wars part uh
re part like everything it's it's really
cool and the soundtrack is actually done
um even though where they're from where
did you say they're from Spain okay um
that's right I'm sorry yeah even though
they're from Spain they actually one of
the guys uh the guy who did the
soundtrack The OST lives in San
Francisco oh sweet yeah good buddy mine
um and he's actually a good Prince with
um way forwards um composer as well a
little crew
man with these games difficulty is often
like the sort of I don't know folks who
who like playing these kind of games
like that ramp up and difficulty how
challenging does this bad boy
get intense I say I say to the dude
who's already dying in the first level
was it's not one of those games like I
made the mistake when I first like first
couple times I played it just thinking I
could just fly from checkpoint to
checkpoint and make it and the enemies
you know as long as I dodg the enemies
they wouldn't you know bother me so are
you promly trying to hit those six out
of 10
checkpoints do you are you you killing
them basically just sort of keep them at
Bay rather than like a score kind of
yeah so at the moment I'm in the story
mode but then there's also a score
attack which scores you on uh stuff you
kill and time and that's where all the
leader boards and stuff are going to be
so that's where the real competition
starts uh s shirro on The Game Spot chat
asks is the a if the a is programs to
come in front of you could you heard
them in front of you for massive combos
so you can like let them in front and
then kind of back up and yeah into them
one of the ships um one of the ships in
K also has like a um targeting so if you
held down the attack button whatever
it'll actually Auto Target start Auto
targeting all of them so you could
Corral all of them in front of
you there are some slight tricky ones
though that attach lasers to you and
start draining your HP so oh really if
you're trying to hurt them yeah yeah the
NPCs are slightly do on BU as well more
the demo thankfully for you
y otherwise I'd probably be dead by now
it's pretty great
looking not sure uh what
ships just going to try another ship
show so there's four ships all of them
have very unique play Styles um
strengths and weaknesses so that was
kind of uh the allrounder ship um it's
got a shotgun so you have a primary that
you can fire constantly and then you got
secondary that has a very low cool down
uh joystick expert only this one says
mouse and keyboard man yeah we're going
we've already got um full controller
support so okay those lazy Gamers when
when is uh out October 24th oh okay next
month again you guys got a busy October
right this one looks like a civil war
tank from the side or Cannon rather this
is my kind of sniper this is my favorite
ship yeah it's it's called the prec one
thing that we didn't show was you can
actually go into first person kind of
cockpit view too oh sweet and there's a
kind of in between stage as well but
this ship is uh heavily reliant on
accuracy so it really helps be
first is this the laser that drains HP y
oh no no that was the enemy's laser oh
right that's your laser this is my I
thought it was like a reward risk reward
thing yeah so that's the secondary um or
your special attack if you want so in
like traditional schupps have bombs um
you have unlimited amount of secondary
Firepower but it actually takes a long u
a longer time to
recharge for this ship specifically yeah
or in the game sh ship you have in the
game there's four total ships all their
secondary weapons will take amount of
time to recharge and their secondaries
have different attributes absolutely
yeah how many ships are in it uh four
total and what about levels how long is
this bad boy is it mostly score attack
stuff or what about the campaign I have
not completed it and I don't there's uh
there's four worlds one for each ship um
I'm kind of racing through doing the
checkpoints all of them kind of have uh
like a side world going on so you can go
and explore the different areas there
are a few puzzles in there as well um
and then once you completed all the
worlds they become kind of score attack
zones and use any ship in any world and
I mean Kraken Empire they want to keep
all the ships competitive and we're
really looking forward to when the game
gets out and the pros get on it and
they've mastered it within a week and
start making you guys look like Chumps
it happens they did that with Cloud
built the people on cloud shout out to
chesda okay we've got a boss coming up
now all
right the boss it's very subtle but if
you look in the center of the
screen traditional schut fashion big the
warning love that all I kill this
honeycomb dude yeah uh I'm I know I've
got first
person I believe in you there you go Bo
I was in first person this you can see
it but that was a last minute b i no you
keep your distance a lot from the bosses
I do that's the laser Built For This is
the sniper
ship if we have time it would be awesome
to show everyone the first melee
spaceship in history no I think there's
a m station got it we we retract that
there's an old schm car I think it was I
don't know but there's another there's
another melee spaceship we not second
best second melee spaceship the coolest
one Rings done is he dead he's gone nice
work got actually well done let's
quickly do the no we got to we got to
keep we got to we got to Barrel on
through such as the The Wonder of the
lobby dudes thank you so much for coming
on Kaya is about 29th is that right uh
24th of October for Kamaya I'm for like
a high five or something sh that 29th
try will be October 9th sweet awesome
and you guys are showing off all your
wares D at the moment best of luck with
that and yeah we'll get in contact when
this bad boys are at and we'll have
another play of them thank you so much
for coming on we've got a bunch more
stuff today on the lobby paper band is
up next we're going to play a gauntlet
after that but first of all we're giving
away a bunch of copies of Destiny the PS
Destiny I know we couldn't go a whole
show without mentioning bloody Destiny
PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 copies Eric
Taye is losing his mind right now that
he's not playing it so are you yeah
really we're sort of on that grind phase
right what happens when you get to level
20 how do you get get your levels up
higher Tay's at 26 trying to do that
raid Mission uh we'll talk about that a
little bit later he's definitely
taunting me he he goes to the depths of
grind that I am not willing to go to no
well if you want to win it PS3 Xbox 360
gamespot.com Destiny giveaway and uh you
can go in there fill in your information
and win a copy uh we'll be back in a
second with paper bound we got an
exclusive build right here in the lobby
but first of all Ubisoft released a new
trailer for Assassin's Creed Unity let's
check it
[Music]
out
the city is in
[Applause]
chaos we must turn the
tide the wind call
to yet here we are standing ground face
to
face the time has come to show and pro
for being
one where are you thought you knew
Coming
Undone is that you reaching or you
wanting to
run stand down or show down baby let's
get this
done you looking at
[Music]
me me looking at you I never thought we
could be pist
[Music]
at we may be
different I with different
skills but when the world is darkest we
fight for the same
[Applause]
[Music]
cause you looking at
me for we are stronger as A
brotherhood
[Music]
[Applause]
together
[Music]
[Applause]
p
make
history Assassin's Creed Unity hey
what's up we're back here on the lobby
I'm here with Eric Tay what up with that
guy hi Christopher Waters me and with
the singer of the paper Band theme song
paper
band damn it Rob Handlery hi gentlemen
we have been bestowed with a a a
entirely new build of paper band with Mr
Dan hbert to create
so I say we all jump in and play some
how you feel about that you Rob you've
played before right I did like for 5
minutes earlier yeah so good sounds
about right what's you say classic
versus yeah let's start with the classic
bam soam for people who don't know who's
got the most experience on this probably
Chris Tay book about killing each other
in books game about book Killing all I
know is Jan Jan really really good at
this stuff H it's got the guys from
Monaco in it which I appreciate so
they've all got like there's there's a
book theme throughout and so like a lot
of these characters some of them come
from The Book of the Dead some of them
are from the book doodle paper I'm going
to go with Jasmine from the doodle paper
nice oh I'm sorry oh no it's too too
close in color that was me uhan from
V and so B you know you got your jump
you got your melee attack you got your
tap to switch gra your own personal
gravity yes and so you can and you know
like jump around and tap that a bunch
and just hover in the middle like my
yellow
gu like
that look alive hey now he now where we
go uh yeah the object is to jump around
and Slash the crap out of each other
murder each other Journey to the Center
of the Earth with Bren Frasier that's
the video game all right uh who's who
I'm I'm vvv green guy I'm the yellow
dude I'm really white I'm Horus I think
is oh
what godamn it get it get it uh we
should mention as well that uh um the
creator of this Mr Dan hbert is actually
in the gam spot chat right now answering
your questions oh hey Dan what up Dan
which makes it so that we can just
murder each other here suck a h oh ink
bombs ink bomb
me get sized you also have two
projectiles every life you've got an ink
bomb and you've got scissors uh that you
kind of Chuck around the
scissors downtown from downtown get
sciss come on who's winning right now
blue blue has n nothing to see here blue
is definitely winning oh that's out when
you win dang it when you win a a tear
opens up in the world and you have to
exit through it oh he's got it he's got
it stop him from exiting stop him from
exiting I'll guard it don't let why are
you camping the hole I'm always because
because then it gives us a chance to win
what was that you heard me you heard me
the first time no let me out no right
there son of a [__] blue ninjetti wins
I was so close whopping forward I'm a
ninja let's pick a different arena in
real life that so this is a skull
Kingdom Indiana Jones yeah there we go
yeah oh this is way every level in this
this is much easier to see bomb get it
get the double check it out I'm
Flo you just got my bom get scissored
ohow I'm pretty sure there's like a like
a slam is what I was trying to say but
yes see is I'm going a freaking roll
here everyone dies everyone gets one oh
Dam it everyone get
one
I feel like I have a uh uh being VV v v
v man I have an advantage with this
whole gravity oh yeah cuz you're a uh
veteran of the gravity floating oh no
don't let him have it wait he's already
no he hasn't got it already someone has
it no that's somebody spawning in
Captain Vian the no oh [__] don't let
him have it I win Ah that's what I was
saying I don't even know you should have
kept your stupid M don't let him have it
you need to be more specific well if I
get green player is winning murder green
player
should Channel your golden ey and Screen
sheet at the top left bottom left not
possible to screen sheet when everyone's
looking at the same screen on purpose
and there's no divisions between it that
this one's a bit mess fine maybe you
should be more aware of your
surroundings oh nice you should get CH
maybe you should get B myself and Rob
are just going to kill each other
accidentally for the entire of this
stream I'm just going to walk calmly
around the exterior be honest these
horses shoes really make it hard to run
fly across the map yeah killing people
look live I like it die son of a
[__] y yep yep so I'm
wondering when do you think we're going
to get sick of catch competitive games
like this because I've still not hit
that
point
never yeah H you can deflect the bombs
as well right uh can you I just tried it
did not work me Chris had one where we
threw the bomb and it uh they bounced
off each other I think did that happen
sounds about right
sounds like sounds like something that
could have happened God damn you in a
world I'm n who's blue I'm a nin oh you
can't deflect that I just deflected it
yeah you did which one's blue I am oh
that a problem you just deflected that
bomb i c you jerk yeah I do that
sometimes oh Dam
it yeah son of a Lun don't you
dare you don't say anything the guy so
close to nine again all right let's back
it up let's back it up so that's uh free
freefor all freefor all FFA what we got
survival what's that is that like you
only have X amount of lives probably
Survival let's try that let's see what
happens I'm going to stick with netti
Ninja Jedi oh wow I'm going upgrading
hor going Mon oh look at that um look at
me hold my bird wings out the bird guy
we changing
characters I'm going to be Mumsy I'm
going to be gentleman Mumsy oh that from
Monaco you love your character from
Monaco the video game Monaco they're
making a new game are they yeah pocket
watch
games H okay three lives are we doing
the three this is going to get real real
quick real lame it out I'm going to lame
it out you going to Camp oh you
deflected my bomb at you sweet son
of who get it get diced nope he bom son
of a son of a dick son of a dick oh
never see a Bullet Storm trailer oh man
oh oh I just got whooped ninja now eh
yeah the mummy apparently the mummy the
oneeyed Cyclops and mummy is this me and
water come and get it mums chopping with
those wings car BS coming to get
you no one-on one baby let's do it
yeah death from a
birded Horus God damn it what a
[__] oh you're just h
r at the beginning that's fine that's
okay it's getting cute with names you I
like it I'm not trying to refer to
anything I was trying to get success of
the video game how about that oh we're
playing oh God don't murder me oh who's
using the I don't know where I where am
I come here did you deflect that oh
swear to God oh you son of a [__] great
is damn it yeah I don't know what
happened but ninjetti will take I forg
we were playing Survival I'm not going
to lie okay you know what you know what
more
lives 10 seems like
oh 11 yeah odd number I was thinking
11 oh yeah you that eat
it l about survival I just killed myself
with
my head got chopped off son of a [__]
got him with that scissors down oh damn
you Mumsy thank you look at this camper
over here yep strategery oh s gy is oh
man so this game is is currently on
steam green light so if you're liking
what you're seeing H do down a flavor
and uh go up that thing yeah do him a
flavor give him some vanilla like that
sweet Pokemon too many people over here
Pokemon oh nice trade there TR I like
that trade I like that trade boom Jesus
I'm just taking names and
and keep getting my bombs deflected oh
midair bombing that was really good I
did do that on purpose where am
I out
oh I'm done wow get light blue he's got
five or six oh thanks for killing me K
Waters hey man it's all in the game not
a good scene all right who's blue Rob
yeah Rob showing blue Chris is
yellow
gentle this is why we don't let Rob win
yeah I know I didn't like that I didn't
appreciate that we got we got some team
games here as well oh we're going team
what's the teams left couch left side
here left side strong side couch vers
chair yeah left side strong side left
side strong side Remember the Titans we
are on the left side from the viewers
perspective so yes we are the strong
side all right maybe it's or maybe we
don't get to choose there's the left
side you're talking about stage left hit
a hitting a got to get I don't know I'm
the top right top right how do we okay
Rob it's me and you all right oh all
right let's Desy Desy Bros team pick the
same dude at least different colors
different colors for the sake of the uh
oh no we can't sorry okay want to pick
want to go
Kaka oh we're going to pick like
literally pick the same dude I went with
the red I don't know if you can where's
the bird Squad I can't get bird just be
I'll be that guy just all right so
you're blue and I'm red yeah listen sure
what whatever whatever super dumb if you
could change pick the same dude on the
same team the same color that would you
would not be able to tell who you were
at all I don't make video games Chris I
only complain of
it all right here we go I don't know
what this game is should we do Labyrinth
obviously we're going into the Labyrinth
score limit 10 is there minor apparently
we have to bring the enemy's quill to
your base what what's your quill oh that
thing ah capture the quill Capture the
Flag this is the best oh what the quill
you want me to do I'm just going to
scooch on over that's protect it we got
to get the the qu back stupid I don't
know what to do you got go on o you got
it I'll play on D what I have the quill
you go on off quill no you don't you're
the tiny blue dude I am red look at me
hovering do you see me doing this we're
not on the same team okay who's on my
who's blue you're blue as well yes okay
iron all right me and Rob Rob get it
done come on gentlemen wow I can't
believe we uh been practicing fig this
out for so long here we go we need to
kill that quill dude I'll do it I'll
kill him oh yeah yeah if you can catch
me it's going to
happen ooh deflected oh he
get it get it get it nice return nice
return [__] we both did oh I didn't get
it now I do now I have I have it I have
it see that sweet quill Robin skill oh
you see that get that guy get that guy
no I didn't get him it's a bad scene go
go go go come at me come at me come at
me
fatty I'm not
fat get come home come homeab yeah dang
it all right this is
rad oh no see you have to you have to
judge there with the see yeah go go go
go go baby you got to be my
fullback I'm
trying [__] vad
scene getting the hell away damn it yeah
good work get get the flag now oh can't
I believe in you Rob I'm floating I'm
floating I believe in you rob wait we
set the score limit of 10 yeah I know I
going to say oh
see maybe this game mode needs like a
timer not just life oh crap
they're getting away they're getting
away score Man play first of five oh
sure sure sure we can do yeah come on
come on this way hey bro come on then
this way come on up here
buddy come on
get get returned get bombed get bombed
get knifed aort I just got to I got to
step up my killing game can I just say I
the the hair on this world is really un
like just kind of horrible creepy what
does it remind you of it reminds me of
testicles just going to come and say it
Rob I need you to get the flag Rob
reminds any specific ones yours Rob
Handler they're really I will take that
oh I don't my scissors take get chped
get chippity chipped all first of three
first of three I won yeah we totally won
you guys got dumped you guys got stomp
five rule Chang okay yeah that
definitely would have changed your fate
we're probably running over time but
let's just have another game cuz this is
good uh How We Do kill the king that's a
different mode I mean capture the quill
was really good was really good let's do
kill the king freefor all kill the king
freefor all so you skull you get a kill
and then you're the king and you only
get points for King for kills while
you're
King dude I'm my guy is so top heavy the
head is going to like he's going to fall
over you're top heavy look at my Sweet
Dome my
Dome I've got the Hat I'm the I'm the
monk with the hat oh yeah I'm a skull
with big teeth skull that's what we call
that's we've been telling been saying
that about you for ages yeah all right
score 11 five launch video
game is this a team game oh no this is
not team he's the king now I'm the king
what was the quote again it's good to be
the king come with the King better not
miss I just can't wait to be
king oh that was nice whoever just
killed the king me who is the king I'm
the king I'm I'm V man ow I do you need
to get two kills with K seems like it
yeah I think you need to get two I think
the first you get one and then when you
key oh yeah no you get one to the king
and then you get another oh no it's not
it's no it's time based it's the longer
the king the better oh oh yeah you just
when need a king just be a camper just
get knifed or scissored rather oh W
scissors me timbers my Timber ooh super
ethereal was like a scissor or something
hey hey he's camping everyone's camping
there's no camping in this game it's not
possible oh this red is doing a great
job damn
it son of
a I forgot who I was I remember hey guys
I'm over here hey guys I'm over here Dam
I'm over look look at Pro oh it's
got damn
it oh get skilled damn it come
on turns out if you just yell get sized
doesn't necessarily ensure that is going
to happen don't you touch him damn it
nobody touched blue are we sure this is
not a match oh God damn
it yeah yeah Dam it I'm having a he no I
was right there how did I notam it God
damn it paper band paper band Steam
green light do us all a favor and just
go to our page and give it a thumbs up
that was pretty good fun yeah thanks
very much uh to Dan hbert for starting
us out with that bad boy uh I'm sure
we're going to make it an office staple
H we'll be back in a second faor fun
Danny did I say off a staple I did by
accident yes success wow we're going to
play Gauntlet in a few minutes but first
of all Ubisoft to put out another
trailer by Far Cry that involves
elephants this is number seven of 24 is
it giving them a bath yes is it like
that Sesame Street video it's definitely
an elephant to bed Splish Splash I was
Taking a Bath they're doing a really
good job of trying to make it like you
can't kill a bunch of animals in this
video game but you can here's a bunch of
elephants killing people
instead
Goa since the dawn of man The Majestic
Asian elephant has been worshiped as a
Godlike symbol of strength and wisdom
with the largest brains of all land
animals they are highly intelligent and
exhibit a wide range of sophisticated
Behavior including learning language and
Tool use elus Maximus is the biggest
mammal in the land weighing a massive 7
tons more than three full-sized cars it
is also the strongest able to carry the
weight of a 100 men and uproot even the
tallest trees it is easy to understand
why these beasts have no natural
predators
deployed by Alexander the Great like a
heavy tank a charging elephant becomes
Unstoppable at 20 mph with its
spear-like tusks formidable trunk and
crushing lmbs the elephant's natural
weapons give it the destructive power of
a true War
Machine the elephant remains a force to
be reckoned with to ride one you must be
bold to challenge one you must be
suicidal fun fact elephants crave the
taste of human
blood and when it comes to
Vengeance an elephant never
forgets Far Cry 4 coming uh well like
about a month away now at this stage I
was really expecting after that fun fact
to have it just be like like
stomp blood human
blood splatter the screen I can't how
far are you going into it Far Cry you
looking forward to that oh yeah dude I
loved Far Cry 3 so much and that E3 demo
with the whole like steel truck truck
off the off the cliff like you know wing
suit sold it's great yeah it's good kind
of wa I have a feeling that might be
like top games of the year like that you
Assassin's Creed like part of me feels
like if it wasn't for big Ubisoft games
there wouldn't be much coming out for
next gen like I don't know I don't know
I'm sorry Destiny okay I'm sorry I like
Destiny just not as much as you guys
anyway speaking of Destiny sorry we're
getting away a bunch of copies on as
well PS3 and Xbox 360
gamespot.com Destiny giveaway get in
there you need to be a Gamespot user
because we need to have a usern name in
there as well so register if you are not
uh but yeah do it in there we're going
to give away let you know who won those
bad boys next week on the lobby uh first
of all we've got four people here and
four controllers and it seems like our
head games have gone and made a new
version of Gauntlet yeah so let's play
this new version of Gauntlet oh my God
chis character okay take it he wants the
valkyrie take it does he I'm going to go
normal I don't want the valkyrie I want
the you guys need to start to get in oh
got him I want the wait did I get him
yeah I did okay move off of it
immediately I you can do multiple
valkries I've already selected it how
come I'm not in here then I think you
can do M Valkyries sheit start
T start where did P3 go I where did P3
go damn it vanished who picked elf you
might want to B up for a second cuz oh
there's P3 we're all in there we're all
in there okay who picked elf I'll killed
him no my little choose the wizard I
can't move your controller and choose
the wizard wait I okay is this inverted
Eric T an idiot you can't you literally
can't move anything it's not working
what what would having
come back let's try that again let's try
that again Hey look it's a new version
of Gauntlet Hey look it's a new version
of Gauntlet let's play it sweet dude
Gauntlet I played this game so much when
I was a kid I'm Apple 2gs all right try
now I'm going to go elf okay I can move
now I'm just going to take Warrior
up yeah do it got it see what happens
when you cause Mischief great and it's
all Dani DWI on Steam so I'm getting all
of the achievements thyra that's what's
most important I'm a wizard har All
right I got the s word a charge I'm the
green dude oh there's a whirlwind what
do I have on B oh I got a shield throw
that's kind of that's kind ofun slam jam
so everyone's got the like that's a shop
we don't need to go there it's too early
to be talking to the shop man I already
completed the first section but I to you
sure yeah you sure okay okay is there a
barrel roll what's the barrel roll uh I
don't know if there's a barrel roll okay
I'm the green dude uh Chris Who Are You
Blue Dude blue lady uh Eric T Warrior
which is what red okay and that means
yellow for you rob right oh I'm
purple okay Rob's color blank okay she
definitely not a purple character Rob
have you oh I'm joking have you had an
eye test recently wasn't that great all
right I'm going to kill everyone with
these oh B's
exploding uh fun fact here that cleave
icon for my warrior looks early similar
to Diablo oh yeah like is it really
close is it like creepy and ooky yeah
sure cooky oh Whirlwind it did any of
you guys play the original Gauntlet back
of the arcade days not the arcade one I
mean I played the original Gauntlet that
came onto my Apple 2gs oh yeah yeah so
much of it was it hard it was hard once
you got to like the higher levels and
you'd like find out the find where the
warp zones were cuz he didn't want to
play every level and then oh eat shield
and then you uh you counter death death
oh I just got lit up oh who's dead me
mer say to revive back in don't worry
bro wizard you live again uh you'd
encounter death who is just this black
cloaked character whenever he would be
on screen it would be on screen it would
just
go that's the worst sorry headphone
users and so in addition to
uh that's the way it was man this is a
realistic portrayal of gaming history
GameSpot is legit websites can we pull
that up then can we verify that Chris is
not let's not do that okay I can hear
myself now
through the office that people are
watching that was great so these are
like monster closets basically where you
have to destroy uh my standard attack
won't work in them so only my charged
Arrow one will so maybe it's the same
for you guys no I'm basically just
chopping on it I'm wiing I guess it's
cuz my I can spam my arrows so much um
so I played this on my own earlier MH uh
it was good fun nothing will stand in
the way of Vengeance we are clearly like
burning through these areas I got a
little boot I got a little like Accolade
there for dealing 60% of the damage to
the uh to the enemy generator hopefully
I get this you're that guy huh Danny
you're the guy that eats the turkey when
you probably didn't even need it yeah
well that's why I'm like the most
overweight of all you guys the guy who
off all the skin like life like video
games I always eat the turkey
leg man I really need just go to a
turkey and pick off all the skin and
that's it we need key we need the key is
it this way oh yeah they totally used to
have these barriers you walk through
with a key and it would just you guys
clip out of existence guys ready I'm
going to use my spe I'm going to leave
with my speci junior speci us mine too
bam guys let's get it coordinated why
they just died our timing and our
clothes have to coordinate all right
like Luda said I'll just take all the
gold guys don't worry about it like Luda
said Luda oh what happened
there uh I don't know some sort of the
the enemies when they hit you can like
knock you back and I've been in
situations where I got knocked back
straight into another enemy so you can
lose a bunch of that Health real quick
yeah I just got knocked back by a
shieldo over
here a
remember your stuff has oh I died say
has cool down my health is low others
abilities I died I died too I didn't die
got two Cavalier well that's because
you're freaking backpedaling with your
rang yeah it's it's it's kind of it's oh
sugar oh you're a whisp what did you
what did you turn into I'm op is what I
am turn into a
whisk gotam then I back baby I died
again you just Rob all my stuff yep
sorry that's what you get for taking
that turkey leg that I needed earlier
just walk it off Merlin you were like
that guy back in the day playing ninja
turtles that always ate the pizza when I
didn't need to yeah I always ate the
pizza when I didn't need to in life and
in Ninja Turtles anyone got a key as in
life so in Ninja Turtles I've got a key
you guys want to like I'm I'm going to
drop a bomb do
it damn it great
coordination that was real good you blew
it onwire oh I died from my sins yeah
Karm gold that was Karma bam I'm going
to Ste he's steal the gold and the
turkey oh I just got
charged touche owire touche so this
game's coming out pretty soon it's like
uh next week next week a we from a week
from today um it's a lot of fun yeah
it's it's it's it's pretty good I feel
like I was having fun with it earlier
playing on my own um I do think it's
maybe a little hey red wizard come over
here and get this turkey it's some hot
collaboration me yeah Wiz no the other
fine oh well red guy you talking about
me the turkey purple dude maybe I have
not my purple guy has not shown up the
whole time I don't understand where he
is H this first section the first like
door that I unlocked M um took like a
good on my own at least solo took like
minutes and it seems to be like I don't
know it's like 15 or so in that main
area but there's probably more there's
also like a classic mode or something
right you want to see the classic Mode
this is really funny classic Mode's
amazing for for graphics check this out
oh yeah I see it already let break it
what the crap do it this is terrible do
it this is not good at all back in my
day this was great it actually looked
way better when it wasn't this back in
the day I think we just walked by a
bunch of gold
because kids in your graphics this just
looks like kind of like sand Quake W
when it gets dark it's so mushy this
this is terrible can we end this oh it's
my turkey we played it like that and we
liked it I love how even the UI is like
we
play oh god there you go it's like I put
my contacts back in I can see it again I
just killed that lady watch out or
something oh is that the boss get a
B oh yeah whoa where your legs
dude how supposed to chop him legs he
got no watch chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop
chop oh thanks for that gold oh no why
did I just get hit
by the enemy's laser beam the green the
green thing was me that little bomb yeah
ow it won't hurt you oh I got froze I
got froze in place by this enemy laser
watch out smash the fire and the
lasers
dud oh I just died they killed Thor
thought you couldn't kill decent amount
of enemy Variety in the first couple
levels too give me the
loot don't plunder my body I did I
really
did remember what happened last time oh
no called it
it I love
gold it's okay guys I got all the gold
for
us are you going to spend it all at the
shop or at the bar oh that's you're just
stereotyping me now oops somebody set
that thing on fire you can carry that
yeah you can pick him up with a I want
to do that and if some jerk sets it on
fire beforehand
should
throw
oh Rob you're the worst I didn't do
anything I just laughed at the idea of
it and you just completely access that
turkey that's down there I don't know
how we're going to get tell me should I
eat turkey I'm trying to lose weight
okay all right tell your Elf that it's
turkey's lean meat you know true also
makes you like sleepy right turkey does
bomb thing is that is that a Monkey
Island reference oh God I'm stuck in my
bomb
area oh jeez everything's cool don't
worry the gold it's okay oh man this guy
charged me twice like a box with his
shield oh he's Whirlwind now oh I got I
got Crossfire World unlimited lives
unlimited quarters Chris unlimited
quarters yep we're grown adults now we
can afford video
games not like when I was playing this
on my computer with a joystick and a
single
button there were two but butons cuz you
would use magic and you would do your
attack you guys didn't want this chest
up here I'll take it a
you probably Global right I would have
seen so I mean it doesn't show us I'm
going to jump off the screen
individually I found the G uh blue and
green probably the Turk uh yeah this
will keep me in the fight so will
defiling sarcophagy nope yeah do I
couldn't do it they didn't they didn't
get I haven't leveled up my defiling
skill yet a
what about your plundering I pillage the
dead SK oh here we go here's some
Esports who's going to be who's going to
be oh I took one oh boy do the jump
thing you guys can do that right is no
my B is Whirlwind oh really my B is
Shield throw oh then that then those
sections are way easier for
me well
typical oh I'm dead I'm a
whisp that's supposed to be able to
cancel th's attacks
not that uhoh he's still
alive Valkyrie I'm assuming if we all
die Oh wait we're all going for this no
I think it's fine just revived yeah I
think so I guess we should all
concentrate on the same area did you
guys so at the past like bunch of uh
game events there's been um oh [__] I'm
dead now food trucks yeah those food
trucks yeah at packs we just see people
around the corner us all walking around
with giant turkey legs I did you you
guys ever get any of the turkey legs no
no the GA truck I know that the the
homeless people were definitely
feasting good they're feasting on those
turkey wonderful doing good for the
neighborhood absolum the people open
hand baby yeah project open hand I was
actually just about to say that watch
out for the bomb Oh that bomb is bad oh
God all right which Stone are we going
for top or bottom knock farts I'm dead
yeah let's concentrate on oh bottom F
that oh no the top one's actually
spawning way worse dud oh God I just got
rocked come on Merlin be the great
wizard that you are
Merlin yeah see if we all die that was
we for everybody I did blew it I was on
you buddy that was on me that was your
hero moment shame shame you almost had
it I'm a real P almost there real P I'm
going go cry later good we ha oh we're
back to the start all right let's not do
that then all right all right what else
what else we got here mastery
oh look all these sweet stuff we can
unlock M that's hot looen food and death
done and online as well gauntlets good
fun right this fun had that Smash TV
kind of vibe for
yeah Gauntlet it's a gauntlet Vibe I
know but it's Gauntlet yeah I didn't
play the old Gauntlet for me did I
mention that I did play the old Gauntlet
actually I feel like I maybe didn't say
that during this play Rob didn't Rob
Rob's 12 did you guys ever play that
like N64 War Gauntlet that was like a
third person action view oh was it like
the Bomberman act zero of The Gauntlet
series yes it was yeah was was it great
there was a dude the Warriors had this
move called blaze a trail that he would
like shoot this triangle of power that
would like you know like everyone but
the audio like was the voice acting for
it was bad so it was like
BL every time you're like what did you
say sounds like the precursor to F Roa
yeah except like mouth that version we
should we should play that one
on so so bad what are you guys doing for
the rest of the week apart from playing
Destiny all day Eric and I are putting
together a feature on what to do once
you hit Level 20 CU there's a lot like
leveling up until 20 is like very
straightforward but then once you hit 20
it's like you can only get your level
higher by getting certain gear and you
can only get that gear through certain
there's certain ways to get that gear
and then there's certain currencies and
reputations and stuff that all come into
play and it's it's not like all
immediately apparent like how you can
like look up FAQs and you can uh watch
our handy video uh like tomorrow or
something there a lookout for sweet what
are you working on I'm working on end of
week a Sims 4 feature yeah I've heard
about this and I'm really looking
forward to it it's basically I created
the
worst POS family what's POS stand for uh
P okay and uh basically I've made them
all so they they love trash they don't
mind stinking up the whole place TR love
trash they're like the more garbage
around the happier my emoji exactly and
I made them so ugly the parents that
they have kids and they look so ugly
it's just hilarious and one of them's
name is carore he's the youngest uh
Devil Boy and he's just got the most
terrifying face but he loves just going
around their neighborhood and talking so
much crap to everyone so and they get
off on that they love like they're not
happy unless they're like just yelling
making people like pissed off sounds
like a bunch of Charmers and what I did
is I also made the house so that all the
uh kids they don't deserve to live in
the house so I have them all in like
little Shacks outside um in little Stone
houses that's where they belong great so
just like you're growing up yeah that's
how that's how I was raised and you turn
that yeah he grew up in the backyard
Castle the dog was first so he got the
bed and I got I got the hay listen you
know showed up first what do you want
hey but look at me now I look great yeah
you know super totally socially
functional only does that like three
times a day all right that's a show
thanks very much every for hanging out a
clever a clever quick little reminder
clever quick little reminder if you want
to win one of those Destinies on PS3 or
Xbox 360
gamespot.com Destiny giveaway and that's
going to be open for a little bit longer
until I think the 21st does that take
that make sense a while we're going to
give uh announc the winners on next
week's show though so you got a couple
days at least to get in on that thank
you very much for watching the lobby
gentlemen thank you very much than
hanging out shout out to Jeremy Dan all
the guys in the back Josh doing their
thing we'll see you guys next week video
games enjoy
[Music]
themo